others McDonald's across the street from
the statue of Mile you know that right
there you can look it up on Google Maps
[__] yin and yang stuff literally you
know they have a yin and yang Burger it
is that's what it's called it's not like
a Royale with cheese it's a Yin and Yang
Yang Burger yeah that's their Big Mac
yin yang do you think they struggle with
American nibs the way we struggle with
Chinese names 100 so if you go over
there and you're like my name is Andrew
Santino they go and they make fun of us
the way we do them my name is I mean
let's be honest they're [__] names
when you look at them on a boy like
written down they look like jigsaw
puzzles it looks like I said what are
you doing are you playing Charades with
[__] pictures they are yeah